All right, let's get right into audience questions.
The first one. Hey David, I am sick and tired
of this daylight saving time BS. Is it finally
time to get rid of daylight savings time?
People often ask this, but really what they
mean is do we want to make daylight savings
time permanent? Um, I believe that it would
be a good idea to stop changing the clocks.
And honestly, I'm actually up for either way,
either getting rid of DST or making DSD permanent.
Um, but my preference would be not to end
DSD but to stay on it for the entire year.
So remember we just ended DST. So now that
DST is over, we have the sun coming up an
hour earlier and we have the sunsetting and
hour earlier. I want it darker earlier when
I'm trying to sleep. I don't need the sun
up. Like for example, this week in Boston,
now the sun sunrise is officially like six
26, 22, I think it was today. Um, six 22 in
the morning. I'm not up that early and if
I am, I'm okay with it being dark still.
If I'm up at six 22 in the morning, I would
much rather a five 30 sunset than a four 30
sunset. And uh, instead, which is what we
have this week in Boston, a four 30 official
sunset. And instead, let it be darker earlier
when I'm trying to sleep. Now I know that
this doesn't apply to everybody's schedule,
but there are way more people who are awake
at 5:30 PM than there are at six 15 in the
morning. Although I know many people get up
that early, I understand I'm not ignoring
you and if you want to make an energy argument
by not needing the lights until an hour later
when there are many more people awake that
would turn on a light. If it's dark at four
30, you have a huge effective net energy savings.
That's number one. Um, there are all sorts
of medical claims that are attributed to the
switch, the switch itself versus it being
light out earlier versus later are sort of
two different categories.
But there are questions about increased car
crashes, workplace accidents, mood and all
sorts of other things. I think that there's
probably, you know, you need to look into
detail to figure out how many of them are
just for the day or two after the switch happens,
meaning two to four days out of the year and
how many are sort of permanent by having the
sun set earlier during the winter, you certainly
have more people commuting home in the dark
when you end D S T my guesses that that also
leads to more car accidents. So 36 States
have introduced legislation to stop the time
change. Some of those say we will stay on
standard time all year. Others say we will
stay on DST, excuse me all year. The main
argument that I hear against permanent daylight
saving is people who get up earlier are going
to get up in the dark and that's not good.
I think that that argument with peace and
love to all of the early risers, I think that
that argument is more than outdone by the
increased safety of more people getting to
commute home in daylight. The increased, uh,
environmental, uh, advantage of not needing
to turn on lights until an hour later in the
afternoon when many more people are awake.
So I am ready to say here today, not end DST
make D S T permanent. I want that extra hour
in the afternoon all year round. Much of the
world. I mean listen, in Argentina in winter,
I think in one aside is sometimes at like
seven 30. It's still pretty dark out. It's
fine. People get used to it in Northwestern
Spain for other reasons because of they're
on the wrong time zone, but it doesn't matter
in Northwestern Spain where my step mom's
from in San Diego that Compostela uh, it often
the son, I think even at 8:00 PM sometimes
during summer it's a, I'm sorry, 8:00 AM until
8:00 AM it's still pretty dark.
But then you get sunlight until like nine
45 in summer and it's a beautiful thing. Uh,
let's get on permanent DST. Tell me if I'm
wrong, please don't cancel me if this goes
against your preconceived notion of the issue.
I'm just telling you what I think at the time.